my new favorite genre of new segment is
now footage of what appears to be a
large flightless bird being a massive
which now the last say it out loud
would be a pretty accurate title for
this show
tonight let's talk about museums let's
talk about psychedelic therapy let's
talk about AI Tech monopolies inflation
of water solitary confine Chuck E cheese
just look at this guy he looks
like an eel wearing a shark costume that
doesn't quite fit a sick eel look at
this mess he looks like he's going
hey Nick Offerman here hi I'm Nina
person I'm the lead singer of The
Cardigans I
it's me
God
look at this utter atrocity
I've quoted the Frog statue Market I am
good at business I Now Pronounce You Man
and cabbage you may kiss the Cabbage
if the next song that you opened a word
doc clippy suddenly appeared and said
pretend I'm not even here and then
started furiously masturbating while
watching you type you'd be pretty
weirded out if Microsoft couldn't
explain why sometimes I just let this
horse write our scripts luckily half the
time you can't even tell the oats oats
give me oats Young
foreign
s into air as if our slow passage
towards Oblivion makes you just not care
hello there Moana hello
there you are truly saving lives just
like doctors nurses and firefighters all
those people are scum compared to me
I am your spirit I'm here to introduce
you to the payback Museum the Liberty
Bell an early American example of a
Bell so welcome to the HOA I
think you're gonna like it here what the
yo oh hey Daniel is strong look out
I'm about to green things up Watch Me
Donkey I want you to watch me look me in
the eyes with great risk comes great
toilet
[Music]
football
foreign